welcome to episode 3 of food flights
today we're making odas no though this
is a traditional Staple in Mexican
desserts I actually had this for the
first time in Costa Rica when me and my
boyfriend now fiance plannned our very
first vacation together when we were
only dating for 3 months but anyway we
made it and in this little town we got
these OD hus they were so good we only
got one because they're so big but I'll
never forget how delicious my first time
eating one of these was they were light
they were Airy they were beautifully
fried coated with this amazing cinnamon
sugar worst part about all of this is I
don't remember what hotel we stayed at I
don't remember what Bakery this was so I
don't know if I'll ever be able to find
it again where I first had it but I'm
happy to be able to make it from home
see you next time on food flight you may
think I'd want to share but I don't